I'm a bit of a perfectionist
now how many times have you heard that
one over drinks maybe with friends or
perhaps with family at Thanksgiving it's
everyone's favorite floor it's that now
quite common response to the difficult
final question a job interview
my biggest weakness that's my
perfectionism is he for someone that
supposedly holds us back it's quite
remarkable how many of us are quite
happy to hold hands and say we're
perfectionists but there's an
interesting and serious point because
our begrudging admiration for perfection
is so pervasive that we never really
stopped a question that concept in his
own terms what does it say about us and
our society that there is a kind of
celebration imperfection we tend to hold
perfectionism up as an insignia of worth
the emblem of the successful yet in my
time stay in perfectionism I've seen
limited evidence of perfections are more
successful quite the contrary they feel
discontented and and dissatisfied amid a
lingering sensor they're never quite
perfect enough we know from clinician
case reports that perfectionism conceals
a house of psychological difficulties
including things like depression anxiety
anorexia bulimia and even suicide
ideation and what's more worrying is
that over the last 25 years we have seen
perfectionism rise at an alarming rate
and at the same time we're seeing more
mental illness among young people than
ever before
rates of suicide in the US alone
increased by 25% across the last two
decades and we're beginning to see
similar
the merge across Canada and in my home
country the United Kingdom now our
research is suggesting that
perfectionism is rising as society is
changing and a change society reflects a
changed sense of personal identity and
with its differences in the way in which
young people interact with each other
and the world around them and there are
some unique characteristics about our
preeminent market-based society they
include things like unrestricted choice
and personal freedom and these are
characteristics that we feel are
contributing to almost epidemic levels
of this problem so let me give you an
example young people today are more
preoccupied with the attainment of the
perfect life and lifestyle in terms of
their image status and wealth data from
Pew showed that young people in born in
the US in the late 1980s are 20% more
likely to report being materially rich
as among the most important life goals
relative to their parents and their
grandparents young people also borrow
more heavily than did all the
generations and they spend a great a
much greater proportion of their income
on image goods and status possessions
these possessions their lives and their
lifestyles are now displayed in vivid
detail on the ubiquitous social media
platforms of Instagram Facebook snapchat
in this new visual culture the
appearance of perfection is far more
important than the reality not one side
of the modern landscape that we have so
lavishly furnished for young people is
this idea that there's a perfectible
life and then there's a perfectible
lifestyle then the other is surely work
nothing is out of reach for those that
want it badly enough or so we're told
this is the idea at the heart of the
American dream
opportunity meritocracy the self-made
person hard work the notion of hard work
always pays off and above all the idea
that we're captains of our own destiny
these ideas they connect our welfare
status and our image with our innate
personal value but it is a course
complete fiction because even if there
were a quality of opportunity the idea
that we are captains of our own destiny
disguise is a much darker reality for
young people they are subject to an
almost ongoing economic tribunal metrics
rankings league tables have emerged as
the yardstick for which merit can be
quantified and used to saw in people
into schools classes and colleges
education is the the first arena where
measurements so publicly played out and
where metrics are being used as a tool
to improve standards and performance and
it starts young young people in
America's big city high schools take
some 112 mandatory standardized tests
between pre-kindergarten and the end of
12th grade the wonder young people
report is strongly to strive perform and
achieve at the center of modern life
they've been conditioned to define
themselves in the strict and narrow
terms of grades percentiles and lead
tables this is a society that preys on
their insecurities insecurities about
how they are performing and how they are
appearing to other people this is a
society that amplifies their
imperfections every floor every
unforeseen setback increases the need to
perform more perfectly next time or else
bluntly you're a failure that feeling of
being flawed and deficient is especially
pervasive just talk to young people how
should I look how should I behave I
should look like that model I should
have as many followers that Instagram
influencer I must do better in school in
my role as mentor to many young people I
see these lived effects of perfections
and firsthand and one student sticks out
in my mind very vividly John not his
real name was ambitious hard-working and
diligent and on the surface he is
exceptionally high achieving often
gained
first class grades for his work you no
matter how well John achieved he can we
seem to recast the successes as abject
failures and in meetings with me he
would talk openly about how he'd let
himself and others down John's
justification was was quite simple how
could he be a success when he was trying
so much harder than other people just
attain the same outcomes see John's
perfectionism his unrelenting work ethic
was only serving to expose what he saw
as his inner weakness to himself and to
others the cases like John's speak to
the the harmfulness of perfectionism is
a way of being in the world contrary to
popular belief perfectionism is is never
about perfecting things of affecting
tasks
it's not about striving for excellence
John's case highlights this vividly at
its root the factionism is about
perfecting the self or more precisely
perfecting an imperfect self you can
think about it like a a mountain of
achievement the perfectionism leads us
to imagine ourself scaling and we think
ourselves once they reached that summit
and people will see on the floor and
I'll be worth something
what perfectionism doesn't tell us is it
soon after reaching the summit we will
be cooled down against the fresh
lowlands of insecurity and shame just to
try and scale that peak again this is
the cycle of self defeat in the pursuit
of unattainable perfection of perfection
is just cannot step up and it's why it's
so difficult to treat now we've known
we've known for decades and decades that
perfectionism contributes to a house of
psychological problems but there was
never a good way to measure it that was
until the late 1980s when two Canadians
Paul Hewitt and Gordon Fleck came along
and developed a self-report measure of
perfectionism so that's right
folks you can measure this and it
essentially captures free core elements
of perfectionism the first is self going
to perfect the irrational desire to be
perfect I strive to be as perfect as I
can be
the second is socially prescribed
perfection the sense of the social
environment is excessively demanding
I feel that others are too demanding of
me and the third is of Oriental
perfection the imposition of unrealistic
standards and other people if I ask
somebody to do something I expect it to
be done perfectly now research shows
that all three elements of perfections
associated compromised mental health
including things like heightened
depression
heightened anxiety and suicide ideation
but by far the most problematic element
of perfectionism is socially prescribed
perfectionism that sense that everyone
expects me to be perfect this element of
perfectionism has a large correlation
with serious mental illness and with
today's emphasis on perfection at the
forefront of my mind I was curious to
see whether these elements of
perfections were changing to date
researching this area's focused on
immediate formulations but we wanted to
look at it a most more a more broader
level so we took all of the data that
had ever been collected in the 27 years
since Paul and God developed that
perfectionism measure me isolated the
data and college students this turned
out to be more than 40,000 young people
from American Canadian and British
colleges and with so much data available
we looked to see if there was a trend
and you know it took us more than three
years to callate all of this information
crunch the numbers and write a report
but it was worth it because our analysis
uncovered something alarming all three
elements of perfectionism have increased
over time but socially prescribed
perfections who saw the largest increase
and by far in 1989 just nine percent of
young people report clinically relevant
levels so she described phases
those are levels that we might typically
see in clinical population by 2017 that
figure had doubled to 18 percent and by
2050 projections based on the models
that we tested indicate that almost one
in three young people will report
clinically relevant levels of socially
prescribed perfectionism
remember this is the element of
perfectionism that has a large
correlation with serious mental illness
and that's with good reason
social protections feel a unrelenting
need to meet the expectations of other
people and even if they do meet
yesterday's expectation
perfection they then raised the barn
selves to an even higher degree because
these folks believe that the better they
do the better that they're expected to
do this breeds a profound sense of
helplessness and and worse hopelessness
but is there hope of course is hope
perfection is can and should hold on to
certain things they are typically bright
ambitious conscientious and hard-working
and yes treatment is complex but a
little bit of self compassion going easy
on ourselves when things don't go well
can turn those qualities into greater
personal peace and success and then
there's what we can do as care games
perfections perfectionist develops in
our formative years and so young people
are more Vaughn parents can help that
you by supporting them unconditionally
when they've tried but fell a man dad
can resist that understandable urge in
today's highly competitive society to
helicopter parent there's a lot of
community as a lot of anxiety that's
communicated when parents take on their
kids successes and failures as their own
but ultimately our research raises
important questions about how we are
structuring society and where our
society's heavy emphasis on competition
evaluation testing is benefiting young
people it's become common place for
public figures to say that young people
just need a little bit more resilience
in the face of these new and
unprecedented pressures but I believe
that is as washing our hands of the core
issue because we have a shared
responsibility to create a society and a
culture in which young people need less
resines less perfection in the first
place let's not kid ourselves
Kurian that kind of world is an enormous
challenge and for a generation of young
people that live their lives in the 24/7
spotlight of metrics league tables of
social media perfectionism is inevitable
so long as they lack any purpose in life
greater than how they are appearing or
how they are performing to other people
what can they do about it every time
they are knocked down from that
mountaintop they see no other option but
to try scaling that peak again
the ancient Greeks knew that this
endless struggle up and down the same
mountain is not the road to happiness
their image of how was a man called
Sisyphus doing fraternity to keep
rolling the same boulder up a hill only
to see it roll back down and have to
start again so long as we teach young
people that there is nothing more real
or meaningful in their lives than this
hopeless quest for perfection then we
are going to condemn future generations
to that same futility and despair and so
I left with a question when are we going
to appreciate that there is something
fundamentally inhuman about limitless
perfection no-one is flawless if you
want to help our young people escape the
trap of perfectionism then we would
teach them that in a chaotic world life
will often defeat us but that's ok
failure is not weakness if you want to
help by young people outgrow the
self-defeating snare of impossible
perfection then we will raise them in a
society that has outgrown that very same
delusion but most of all if you want our
young people to enjoy a mental emotional
and psychological health then we will
invite them to celebrate the joys and
the beauties of imperfection as a normal
and natural part of everyday living and
loving thank you very much
[Applause]